Many of you may have experienced doubts
about certain future technological
advancements.
I mean don't deny it's a fear of
technology,
of artificial intelligence,
of autonomous cars or factories with our
work as a smart robots,
it's totally fine if I think of odd jobs
being taken away.
If a few gaining power at the expense of
others,
inequalities multiplying,
it's even machines controlling us and
taking over the world.
It's scary stuff.
Well,
but I'm an adult.
I always pickwick,
no enemy and this boy my arm.
It's like kind of machines really
replace human beings.
Could they really manage to teach
themselves and take control of
civilization?
What role are people going to play in a
world of intelligent machines folks,
this fear of change of the unknown of
the future.
Has it become something like our own
21st century Phantom,
a fanzine that is now moving all around
the planet.
Although you know what?
Truthfully,
this is nothing new.
The relationship between human beings
and machines,
it's never been simple.
It is always awakened.
Mixed Feeling,
oh go has landed cause that the same
noise you heard when you signed your
sportswear contract.
Fair them.
Then there's others.
Even as an opportunity for progress,
there are those who view them with
distrust and those who view them as
great allies,
and of course there are always those who
predicted that because of all these
machines,
the end of humanity is getting nearer.
By the way,
before we can send you,
what group do you belong to,
you let me know in the comments below
and also we've got a survey about it at
the end of the video.
So check that out.
And of course along with all these fairs
are the typical contradictions that
always arise just because the machines
take our jobs and at the same time we
complain about the mundane and
exhausting jobs to which many employees
are subjected,
especially the least qualified ones or
for example,
another very typical contradiction.
Almost every day we hear union leaders
demanding a shorter work day while at
the same time rejecting or wanting to
hold technology,
which you know would actually lead to
that shorter work.
Yeah.
Then
there's one of my favorites.
Many politicians continually denounce
workers,
low purchasing power while they place
obstacles and even pro habits
technologies that increased productivity
and lower prices.
Maybe you've thought about the taxi
sector runs platforms like Uber.
We at visual politics certainly half of
course to view it in the end,
adapting to new changes.
It tends to be just a matter of time.
Do you know a single person who worries
about jobs that have disappeared because
of mobile phones?
Do you know anyone who wants to ban
electric power because it can hard to
candle factory workers,
but it's true.
As we mentioned before,
the arrival of artificial intelligence
has led to some questions and some new
challenges,
but before we talk all about that,
let's look back at the history.
Okay.
Fear of change.
Sure.
The political speeches we hear everyday,
they pose nothing new and the lungs
raised about technological changes.
They come directly from such speeches.
Seek from the very beginning,
from the time human beings lived in
caves,
humanity has progressed thanks to the
use of tools together to cultivate.
Do you conserve food,
ought to improve productivity.
It's all because of tools.
Tools have given us the chance to
achieve better lives.
In fact,
nowadays,
community is experiencing the greatest
welfare and all of its history.
Sure.
However,
during a particular moment in history,
tools and machines became something like
an enemy to be beaten,
at least for a certain part of society.
We're of course talking about the time
of the industrial revolution.
This is despite the fact that the
industrial revolution meant a huge leap
in terms of welfare for billions of,
yeah,
does that at the time,
machines began to be used widely.
Protests against them multiplied and its
movements of all kinds emerged against
the use of new technologies.
The basic argument was that so many
machines would leave artisans,
workers and peasants out of what.
Okay.
Famous of these reactions was that of
the Luddites who you were at the
beginning of the 19th century,
promoted attacks against factories and
especially against machines.
They hated them with all their might and
of course had to destroy them because a
world with machines would be terrible.
Between you and me,
let's just say that,
thank goodness they didn't get their
way.
I mean,
can you really imagine what life would
be like?
But before we continue,
here's a question.
What do you think about trains?
Do you like them?
Do you think they useful or maybe you
consider them dangerous?
The channels is,
are you probably think that they're
worth having around.
While the eighth president of the United
States,
President Martin van Buren,
he wouldn't agree with you as Michael
Cox and Richard Alm tell us in that
book,
myths of the rich and poor,
why we're better off than we think.
In 1829 Martin van Buren,
who was very concerned about the dangers
of the railroad,
he was so concerned that he even wrote
to the president,
Andrew Jackson,
to asking to push a railroad ban.
Yep.
You heard that,
right?
Martin van Buren thought that the
railroad would risk the jobs of
thousands of people who worked in
deliveries and in canals and boat
construction.
In fact,
since Van Buren also thought that it
ships were essential to defend the
United States,
so you considered the railroad to be a
serious threat to national scale.
Not all in that same letter addressed to
President Andrew Jackson.
Van Buren also warns about the danger of
a transportation system that moved a
whopping 24 kilometers per hour.
Yeah.
Yes.
These arguments,
they do seem a bit ridiculous nowadays,
but at the time,
many people took these ideas very
seriously and it's okay.
It's true.
Technological changes have caused
difficulties throughout history.
Think for example,
about what happens with the development
of telecommunications.
See Wenzel often.
He became massive in its early days.
When you wanted to talk to someone,
you gave an operator the name and
surname of the person you wanted to talk
to.
Rehab.
Would you call it the charges on this
for me,
please?
One moment please.
The second half of the 20th century,
which really wasn't so long ago,
tens of thousands of operators worked
connecting long distance calls.
There's of course,
made the calls very,
yeah,
stock tag,
the world's smallest slightest cellular
phone.
I can see the battery,
one of the phone or anywhere like this,
man,
how are you?
By 1980 technology allowed
communications to be made directly
without any intermediaries other than
need.
The operators became irrelevant in the
calls became very,
very cheap.
So the question is what happened to all
of the operators?
Well,
they had to find new jobs and yes,
I know adapting isn't always easy,
but evidently this change until often it
was very beneficial for society as a
whole.
Communications,
it became easier and much cheaper.
That's why the important thing is to
generate lots of employment
opportunities within a society and to
make it relatively easy to change jobs.
Can you just imagine if a state,
if a government had forbidden these
positions from disappearing,
that country's communications would
still be very slow.
People would sometimes have to wait
hours to speak with someone and cools
would be very expensive.
All of this would have made the economy
and the total number of jobs in that
country.
Not very good because folks,
we tend to forget one thing now as you
watch this video,
your going through the time in history
where technology is used them.
Yeah.
See,
you know what?
It's also the time where people worked
the most.
In fact,
it's curious,
but the countries that use the most
robots are precisely those that suffer
the least unemployment,
which is definitely not a bad thing.
Now,
some of you might be thinking,
come on Simon,
artificial intelligence,
that's going to be different.
Well,
let's dive into that.
Are you listening?
I'm of a,
I,
Debbie.
Have you,
uh,
the time of artificial intelligence and
robots,
it's already here.
Everyday we use more products and more
services that function with artificial
intelligence from voice assistants do
the autonomous cars that are already
beginning to circulate.
And yes,
the speed with which this intelligence
progresses is certainly impressive.
We could say that artificial
intelligence involves applying the
enormous power of computers to solve
problems.
Well,
in the last 30 years,
the cost of computing capacity,
it became 200 times cheaper.
To give you an idea of what this means,
we could say that if the car industry's
cost to devolved in the same way today,
high ends car would cost only for 10
thousandths of what it does.
Now,
this would make it cheaper than a single
Venezuelan boulevard.
And yes,
they've all of our under Nicolas Maduro,
we won't eat those.
This evolution is precisely what
explains why today a playstation four
costs less than $400 even if it is about
2000 times more powerful than the Cray
to supercomputer.
One of the most famous computers in
history,
which beat all records back in 1984 and
this computer,
unlike the playstation four weighed two
and a half tons and cost $18 million.
Today a playstation four can perform 1.8
4 trillion floating point operations per
second.
This would take a person approximately
60,000 years to do and it's precisely
this enormous calculation capacity that
allows ais to replace us in several
tasks.
For example,
sooner or later the autonomous car will
end up imposing itself.
We simply wouldn't be able to compete
with its calculation abilities,
especially now that these machines have
managed to perceive their environment
thanks to cameras,
microphones and sensors.
So yes,
based on how things are evolving,
it seems almost certain that in a
relatively short time,
many mechanical and routine jobs from
factories to the field will be carried
out by smart machines.
It means the productivity will increase
the lawsons with us.
That also means most people's well being
will also increase.
I think the next 30 years people will
only work four hours a day and maybe
four days a week.
My grandfather worked 16 hours a day and
the farmland and he thought he was very
busy.
We work eight hours five days a week and
we think we are very busy.
Jack Ma,
chairman of Alibaba and no Dallas.
During this time,
many new jobs will be created of all
kinds because you see,
the question we may want to ask
ourselves is how close are the machines
to surpassing us?
Well,
for some tasks that really close,
but for many,
not really.
You see,
machines can compete very quickly,
but they have problems learning.
Computers are very inefficient learners.
They only recognize patterns after
analyzing something.
An overwhelming number of times since
this is humanity's great advantage,
the most advanced machine learning
systems require thousands of examples to
acquire new concepts.
While humans can generalize from a few
examples.
Many animals can learn from a limited
number of experiences,
but humans seem particularly good at
generalizing based on just a few
experiences.
Greg Corrado,
Stanford neuroscientist and director of
augmented intelligence at Google.
This explains why nowadays humans are
far superior in areas such as
creativity,
innovation,
intuition,
and empathy.
Folks,
nobody can predict the future,
but until now,
machines have always meant more jobs and
better welfare for all
in the near future.
It's almost certain that what is already
happening will continue to happen.
Some jobs will be destroyed and many
others will be created and also need
highly qualified ones,
but jobs of all kinds,
and it's probably working hours will
decrease and to real wages will
increase.
Beyond that.
It's very hard to predict what may or
may not happen,
but let's not fall into the same
mistakes that former US president Martin
van Buren fell in Duke during his fear
and rejection of the railroad.
There are still many challenges to
overcome in the world such as poverty
and environmental sustainability and the
machines.
They can really help us a lot.
But now as the alternate,
what's your perspective on ai?
Do you leave your comments below as well
as in this survey?
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
Also,
this channel is made possible because of
our patrons on Patrion.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
We won't eat them.
Solution,
start tagging the world's smallest,
slightest cellular phone.
I can't even feed the battery.